welcome to the video series of mobile
explained in three minutes where I
explain the concept of Mobile in less
than three minutes or so today we'll
talk about differential scanning
fluimetry this particular technique is
used to measure protein unfolding by
monitoring the change in fluorescence as
a function of temperature increase
so in this technique we use a
hydrophobic dye which is known as cypro
orange that can bind to the hydrophobic
residues of the protein in the native
state generally the hydrophobic residues
are not exposed that's why very little
amount of dye could bind but when the
temperature increases and the protein
denatures more and more dye can bind so
if we plot this data in a fluorescence
level versus temperature graph we can
notice that at the initial stage when
the protein is in its native
conformation very little amount of cypro
orange can bind because this dye is
dedicated for hydrophobic amino acids
which present which are present in the
core of the protein now when the protein
denatures the dye binds and the
fluorescence increase over time looking
at similar kind of graph one can
deduce many things so simply
folded State means less fluorescence and
unfolded state means more fluorescence
so let's say we have two protein and
they have the DSF curves like this so we
can tell from this curve that protein a
has more thermal stability that's why
it shows fluorescence at a higher
temperature compared to the protein B
now at a technical level if we look at
the DSF machine it has three core
components one is the fluorescence
detector which detect the
ciprofluorescence the Peltier block
and the sample plate
so the Peltier block is used to change
the temperature of the machine so
whenever we want to change the
temperature gradually and rapidly
in this case Peltier devices are used
for example we use this similar devices
in PCR
on top of that sample plate is loaded
where cypro orange is incorporated and
the fluorescence from the sample is
detected by this fluorescence detector
let's talk about the applications of DSF
it includes analyzing protein stability
analyzing or to detect ligand protein
ligand interaction
also analysis of protein aggregation
you can get notes and flashcard in my
Facebook page and Instagram page
definitely follow me
you can support the channel by super
thanks and see you in next video